i don't know what to tell because like
i'm scared scared all the time we don't
know how to sleep because when you fall
asleep you just can't
hear the air raid and you need to jump
out from the flat and just like
uh do something like this because uh
you hear the plane and it it goes right
uh above you and
your house can be just the next i'm in
harkief and we
uh we're here from the very first day
and like uh it's
pretty scary now here because the
missile's attack uh attacks are like all
the time and uh
several days they're just
they're just shooting and shooting
they're destroying our town and uh
our city center is destroyed uh and
every time uh you hear their plane
you're just uh
you just know that you need to hide and
it's it's just horrible we're sitting
here you you see it's uh it's not a very
good place we just have two candles no
electricity for right now in uh in our
ways
so
that's scary my husband will will not
have the ability to leave the city so
me neither i wouldn't uh leave and our
families
my grandfather my grandmother my mother
they also don't leave the city because i
need to help them and
like that's
that's how you behave in these
situations you will not let them be
there
alone i'm pretty sure it will stop
because our
[Music]
ukrainian
guys they're just
they're really heroes they do everything
to protect us and uh
i'm
just still thankful for them for that
for they doing this the world is doing
everything for ukraine as as i can see
and i know that huge corporations
uh are closing their relationship with
russia
the only thing i think we need for now
is to close the sky
above ukraine